Very excited to have Karen here.
Karen has a long storied history at Google.
She joined Google in 2002 and was here through 2011 and worked as a media
liaison.
I really watched a lot of the things that you've taken for granted here at
Google,
including the blog,
uh,
and our Twitter account and much of our outbound has flown through her income
from her ideas.
She later went on to be an editorial director at Twitter and was there I think
six years,
about five,
we'll give her five.
And so she's had really kind of a,
a firsthand experience at some of the biggest names in tech and really the
world.
And you've had a front row seat to that.
And it's been interesting to see your career flourish and grow even after you
left this small little company.
And it was good to see your stories when you wrote this book,
which is taking the work out of networking,
which is really an introvert's guide to networking.
Uh,
one thing that's been fun for me to see is that I feel like everybody knows
Karen or they've known of her or she has been one step away from other people
that we know.
I managed to go through this book and really take a lot out of it.
And so I'm glad you're here to talk about it.
And me too.
We probably have a few introverts in the room who could benefit from it.
So first why don't you tell us,
why did you write a book for introverts?
Uh,
well,
uh,
I'm thrilled to be here.
I love Google and if long left Google so it's great to be back in the plex,
uh,
as it were.
Um,
I wrote the book to see if I could break down in detail the things I have done
to create a sort of big virtual network for myself.
And it wasn't that I woke up one day and said,
wow,
I have a fantastic network.
It's more than other people over the years have often said to me,
you seem to know everybody.
And,
uh,
I would be the one for the hot years.
And Google,
as he said,
as Lewis said,
it was here from 2002 when hiring really turned up and,
and Google was getting a million resumes a year,
it might still,
I don't know.
But there was a point where that started to happen and I was getting inundated
from all my other contacts everywhere I want to work at Google,
I want to work at Google.
And I generally will say yes to most meetings or calls or hangouts or something.
I would,
I would connect with everybody that wanted head questions.
The answers would vary obviously,
depending on a lot of things.
But during that time I,
as I was sort of telling people maybe how to go about navigating Google and
applying to Google and thinking about it,
it sort of led me to think how,
how can I caught a Fi,
uh,
how people not just do a job search but also,
you know,
extent like be able to call on other people,
uh,
when they have questions,
when they need something because we all have those moments.
So fast forward a few years and I wrote a column for what used to be called back
channel,
which is now part of wired.
Steven Levy,
uh,
was the editor.
Um,
and it was essentially building,
building off of my many meetings with uh,
either job seekers or people that wanted to move into tech businesses from some
more traditional industry or something like that.
And I,
I kind of went through the same thing and I thought,
you know,
I need to really kind of detailed this.
So fast forward again,
I've left Twitter,
uh,
got uh,
a book agent and a couple of New York editors called me and we kicked around a
bunch of ideas for books.
And finally someone asked me,
what is the one piece of advice that you find yourself always giving people?
And I said,
it is to build a network for life.
Introvert didn't really come into it except I'm an introvert,
so I'm not,
I've never not built a network on the basis of me being a famous celebrity.
I've,
I much more prefer not only my,
not that,
but I much more prefer a kind of a background role and I still have done it.
And so that's what made me think,
okay,
let me kind of break this out for people.
Uh,
so the book is for introverts,
but not only introverts because in the process of doing it,
I discovered everybody hates networking.
Everybody hates the idea.
Everybody thinks of it as a chore and that it's Phony and uh,
you know,
it,
it doesn't seem to yield much very effectively.
So I thought this is,
this is the way I want to go with,
make something,
uh,
you know,
approach in a way that's more useful for all kinds of people.
You talked about networking being a chore.
I think most people use it.
They don't like it,
they don't want to do it.
That's especially true for introverts.
Many times when you talk about networking,
you're talking about it from the phase of a job seeker.
Yes.
And yet there are people who have stable jobs who don't plan on leaving.
So who cares?
You know?
So why was somebody who's in a stable job want to do networking and why is it
important for them?
Thanks.
You have a stable job for the rest of your working life.
I mean,
honestly,
I,
I've talked to people who did think that until their job wasn't stable,
right?
Uh,
until you name any kind of change happened that they weren't happy with or you
know,
there are lots of circumstances happen.
And so the idea that you,
it's a kind of one and done thing.
Uh,
it just isn't reality for most of us anymore.
But I also think the value of once kind of personal connections and contacts or
as I the subtitle making connections that count,
uh,
is it really something we do want to be able to call on people who have subject
matter expertise and experience in this specific thing when we're looking for
that specific thing.
So job's a big category,
but not only,
but I have literally talked to people who have said,
I'm coming to you because I let my network go.
How do I start again?
Because I've been in a job I'd been happy in for a long time and now I need to
make a change.
So one thing I've run into,
and you talked about it in the book,
was that there's this perception that networking or the process of it requires
you to not be yourself and be fake to put an artificial representation of
yourself and filter out the things you don't think people want to know.
Yeah.
Do you find that that's true or do you find by being your true self in full,
you have the most access to New People and new ideas?
I think when you're authentic and you're not in the clutch of kind of fear it
neediness and you know,
feeling the need to be in a transactional mode with someone you don't know at
all,
uh,
that's a,
that's a position of vulnerability to be sure.
That's not fun for the person who's in it.
But you know,
the more you find a common points of connection,
even with people you don't know,
uh,
the easier it will be to remember later.
Oh,
you know,
I like that person was easy to talk to or I like that person.
Maybe they're going to know about this.
All right.
I know they do know about this other thing.
I'm asking a different role.
A different company.
They lived in another country.
I'm thinking of,
you know,
whatever it is,
I that person is approachable and I think that's the way that we all want to
connect with each other.
And so you know,
why not sort of put it to practice.
You know as,
as we go along
in 2000 as a.com bubble was popping and you start to,
if you look at your linkedin and they start to be instead of five year chunks,
they're like one year chunks.
Right.
And I think a lot of people in the valley,
especially,
you talk about it,
but we have three year job cycles.
So you came to the end of one of these one year job cycles and it was really
hard to find a dedicated role and it was for a lot of your peers.
And you talk about this story of you creating almost like a support group where
you connect with each other and say,
so how's it going?
And as you told it,
that eventually led you to a contract role at Google a couple of years later.
So why was this your job?
How did it fall to you to put together this group?
Because that shows to me someone who isn't necessarily that introvert stay at
home role but more of a leader.
How did you get this?
Well,
I don't think those are opposite things.
Um,
so I am an introvert,
stay at home when it comes to,
if I've had kind of a long stretch of being out and about.
I,
the mental calculation is how soon can I go home,
right?
Or like when can I get some respite from being out in the world?
But I go back out into the world.
So,
uh,
the,
the thing I really am at root is a connector of people.
And I also thought it was true.
There was this big downturn in 2000 2001,
nobody was hiring jobs just melted away.
I mean it was,
it was at first for the bay area for Silicon Valley and uh,
so I knew a bunch of people who had been looking and now there was really no,
there were no jobs listed anymore.
So I,
I thought,
well,
we need to kind of keep each other going.
So I,
I asked a few people I knew at some better than others.
Um,
some form of work colleagues,
I think there were eight of us or so,
and we would meet around my dining room table in the city.
I think we met weekly,
but it might've been less frequent.
But the idea was,
you know,
talk over,
what leads you're finding if you need help describing yourself or if you want to
be for the time being a consultant,
what are your services,
what's your pricing?
Let's just kick it around because we got to kind of feel our way through this.
And that group did meet for probably the better part of two years on and off,
just because it was a long period of people,
you know,
practicing their elevator pitch or maybe I'm going to be interested in this and
I got to go do some research about that.
It was,
it was,
uh,
it was a good lesson for me.
And I think I,
it's,
I do turn to other people for advice and for guidance,
and I want those people to be,
not random,
but people who know,
know the environment I'm in and what I'm interested in.
And that,
that was kind of the purpose of this group too.
So,
uh,
it,
I did go,
I did move from my support group,
but then at the dining room table to a contract as a marketing writer for Google
in 2002.
However,
I knew the first VP of comms here whose name was Cindy Mccaffrey,
because I'd worked with her at two other companies prior.
So I had kept up with her.
I'd visited Google,
not on university,
but in the,
in the first of the office park complex is just over here.
And,
um,
you know,
I,
the other thing,
I had been doing this freelance writing for trade publications.
So I actually got,
I reviewed Google as a search engine and I dunno,
something like,
uh,
maybe 2000 just as a freelance thing.
And I remember that's how I knew Google is that I've looked at it and it was so
many leagues better than all the other,
you know,
20 search engines that had come before.
Uh,
so I thought,
wow,
they've,
they've got something to sing,
really works.
I gave it a good review anyway,
you know,
I came to have lunch with Cindy one day and uh,
I thought,
wow,
that's,
you know,
it's interesting and I just kept in touch with her.
I did call her when I was on the lookout for freelance work and initially she
said,
we just hired a marketing writer.
So right now we're fine,
but I'll keep you in mind.
And then she called me back and said,
actually,
we're drowning in work.
And that guy had to go on a leave.
How soon can you come down?
And so it was September 3rd,
2002.
While I do not forget this date.
Um,
and I had to,
it wasn't just a matter of Cindy than I had to meet other people on the team and
start talking about specific projects I'd be doing.
And within a couple of weeks I thought this is where I want to be.
And rather than work at home and send things in,
I,
I said I'm going to be,
I'm just going to be here and make them get sick of me.
I mean,
I'm just going to,
I'm going to be here and remind them that I want a job here.
And it took a while,
but that was how it happened.
Yeah.
And you mentioned earlier you made a comment about Google getting a million job
applicants and day trying to get it.
Yeah.
So that sounds like the world's changed a bit and you've gone from 2000 where
there's not enough jobs available and trying to get into a small company of 600
or so.
When you started to literally tens of thousands when you left,
and I hate to say it,
but has gotten bigger since she left out.
I know I didn't have to hit 50,000 when the Motorola acquisition with.
Right.
And so there's been a lot of change and you were kind of a,
a front row seat to a lot of that change.
So how did that change your approach to both networking and communication?
Because now you have this tremendous stage and you've all of these people who
want your attention and you have to be a filter as well.
Right?
So on the,
uh,
the,
the first part of that,
the thing that I learned at Google that I'd never really,
I'd never worked for a company that had grown so big so fast.
Um,
people had said to me,
you have to be kind of entrepreneurial when you're at Google.
You know,
it,
you have a lot of room to explore and make things happen.
It did really,
I didn't know what that meant really at the beginning.
It didn't really sink in.
But the thing that I did discover pretty early,
I was part of the communications team when I finally did get a full time job.
Communications as a team has a wider view of a company than almost any other
team because between all the people,
uh,
on their beats,
um,
they're,
they're aware of corporate stuff,
you know,
product stuff,
employees stuff.
I mean,
they're,
as a group collectively,
they have a really wide horizon,
which I did like because I was a kind of,
I worked with everybody.
I was a floating,
I was,
I was an editor.
It was essentially like the editor that became the editor of the Google blog.
And,
uh,
so in that process,
not only was I working with different people along the way,
but I also realized as I became friendly with people,
they became like my brain trust to help me understand what's happening around
the company.
Not,
not,
you know,
secret launch plans,
but more like,
uh,
early on,
you know,
I have liberal arts degrees.
I mean,
I really didn't even understand the search index in the beginning.
So I,
if I,
if I was friendly with an engineer who did know about,
and they did,
I could,
you know,
like,
help me understand this.
And out of that came the original thing that was called Google Zeitgeists,
which is now Google trends.
But at the time it was a handpicked from the index,
printed out 50 sheets of paper highlighting things that we thought were spikes.
I mean it was,
it was primitive,
but he was very patient with me and help me understand what that was about.
So then when I had questions about things like that,
I could,
I could go to someone like him,
I'd say,
does this make sense to you?
Or,
you know,
as I began to understand more,
he was like a good reality check.
And so were other people across,
you know,
legal and product and product marketing and just different ones.
I mean,
Peter has been here all this time and,
uh,
we,
used to work on the mighty Google research blog,
which was anomalous to the other blogs.
But that was,
it was awesome.
It had,
it had its own,
its own personality.
So,
um,
I think you have to have your internal network,
especially in a big company that are just informal friends.
You know,
companies not this big.
You can imagine people saying at the water cooler,
I'm so excited about that lunch tomorrow when somebody is saying,
really does legal know about that yet?
Because I'm not,
you know that,
that I hope doesn't happen here anymore.
But,
but you can appreciate that it has a value to ongoing business,
but it also just enriches your experience so that you understand all the parts
of the business and who's doing what and that people are looking after and
focused on different things.
To me it's,
it's very enriching and I don't know how you can navigate in a company today and
not do that.
And so networking itself is kind of a private activity.
Yeah,
it's talking one to one.
You non-broadcast you mentioned Peter by his first name because to you he's
Peter till I said the people in this room,
he's that guy sitting over there.
And so you have a different level of knowledge base on how well you know them.
So you were able to see Google transform in two ways.
First was going from private company to public.
And the second in terms of having that one to one relationship with reporters to
the point where you can broadcast on your own with your blog and Twitter later.
So this is kind of a dual pronged question,
kind of take us through those stories because a lot of people weren't in the
room.
Talk about going public at Google and Twitter.
He did it twice.
And then talk about how did you get a company to go public with a blog and start
to share with the rest of the world.
So Google is a fantastic story about this because a Google Bot Pyra labs in 2003
which was blogger and from the beginning,
I mean the comms team,
you know,
we all said this is what we should use for our own publishing or you know,
it sort of corporate publishing mechanism instead of press releases,
which was the old fashioned way we googled it and put out that many press
releases to begin with.
And that it's a very arcane way of doing things,
not,
not Google style.
So there was not a lot of,
uh,
opposition to the concept at all for the question was more,
well,
how,
what's the sort of approval flow in the workflow and things like that.
And um,
it took awhile because I think we first kind of announced and published or
unveiled the Google blog in,
uh,
the spring of 2004,
after,
uh,
we had filed for the IPO.
So the lawyers were great,
but they were also a little weary about,
you know,
this,
this all has to be,
uh,
you know,
sort of under the rules of business as usual.
No,
no wild stuff here on blogs.
At that time,
people were very anxious about corporate blogs because typically it was more
like an individual employees doing it right rather than a company.
In fact,
the blogger guys at the time said,
a company can't have a blog.
And I said,
it just a publishing platform,
it's not a,
you know,
yes they can.
And then we're going to,
so eventually we got going.
But if you look back at the very beginning of the Google blog,
it's like,
here's a recipe from Charlie.
You know,
it was,
it was the safest,
most non newsworthy stuff because that was all we could sort of get past the
lawyer.
So it took getting past the IPO and then getting some cadence and then
eventually I could,
you know,
kind of institute and editorial calendar because I was on the comms team,
I made sure all the comms people were signed off on the individual topics.
Uh,
individual team members from the relevant team would be the writer or at least
drafter of the thing because they were the subject matter experts.
That was from the beginning and I didn't realize it then,
but Google really kind of paved the way for what other companies do in terms of
their own news and information because I made sure it wasn't just product
announced with product announcement.
I wanted interesting stories to come through.
And then over time,
more countries,
more products,
uh,
all wanted their own blogs.
And at one point,
I think we were up above 200 and something.
And that's why there's now this streamlined thing that my wonderful success or
Emily would has put into place.
But,
uh,
and Twitter,
adding Google,
uh,
as a,
as a Twitter account was something I made a case for internally.
It was 2009.
Twitter was already the techies.
We're already a busy on Twitter.
And so we're tech reporters.
So that was my argument.
We had to have a presence there because tech reporters were using it already.
And initially I got some pushback because I,
2009 Google,
I,
plenty of public channels and I,
I'm just said,
we,
because of the kind of company we are,
we have to be there.
And uh,
initially it was we'll have headcount and I said,
you don't need head counts.
This is,
I can do this.
It's not,
it's not a 24,
seven job.
And so,
uh,
I did get the okay to do it,
which was awesome.
And the first tweet was,
I'm feeling lucky in binary,
which was our,
it was a big hit at the time.
It's just because it was different than it sort of announced us.
So,
uh,
um,
but happy that I was part of that and that's how those things happened.
Now,
Twitter is like a different generation practically in terms of as a,
as a company publishing its own stuff.
Yes,
of course they had a Twitter account,
but they,
by the time I got there,
the founders were all gone.
So they didn't have a sort of voice of Twitter biz anymore.
And it was frankly a bigger challenge to have Twitter rep,
the company represented on its own platform.
Ironically,
it was a lot and they had less to talk about and there was less they wanted to
talk about they were having,
you know,
it was not a great time at Twitter,
at Twitter back then.
So it was tougher to get a cadence going.
But,
um,
I did kind of institute the same idea of principles about the,
what the blog should be talking about and
all the names that should be attached to post and stuff.
And then,
uh,
it,
it has morphed a lot even since I've left in terms of how they do it.
I mean,
so much has changed really even over the last five years in terms of sort of
company news and information.
So we talked about this a little bit over lunch,
but working at both Twitter and Google,
you've had to work with some seriously introverted leadership.
Right.
And so how do you encourage people to whom networking is not very easy and
speaking publicly is not very easy to actually go out and do that?
How do you tell them this is a valuable thing and get them to engage?
Well,
fortunately that didn't all fall to me,
uh,
to do.
Um,
I found,
you know,
I mean my goal is always to be genuine and helpful honestly.
And so I was in situations where I could do that,
but I was not the advisor talking about media opportunities as much.
I did know that,
um,
someone like a Steven Levy who's an editor at large at why are you now,
who's the guy who wrote the big book about Google?
He was a perfect kind of comfort level for lots of people here and that made it
a lot easier for him to get access and write that book.
Um,
and if you don't know,
I think it's still a good book to explain how Google approaches problems.
And thinks about things in the,
in the plex.
Um,
so it depended on,
I mean I would never be in a situation to push,
you know,
uh,
a broadcast TV interview.
Other people would do that.
But I could suggest maybe the off more offbeat sources that had credibility or,
or the more interesting ones that were not necessarily the biggest following but
maybe had influence in areas that the founders are,
some of the executives would care about.
You talked about blogs and obviously Twitter having its own Twitter account,
which brings us into this new generation,
like you said,
of social networking.
And so in your book you go through and talk about a mix of real life networking
and also social networking.
What do you think that percentage should look like?
You know,
can someone get away with being a keyboard jockey and just doing email and just
tweeting just enough and just posting Instagram just enough so that you have the
kind of loose ties it reference constantly new book?
Yeah,
you can.
I mean that,
that's part of the point of my book is I wasn't like conferred with a lot of
power and visibility that people would want to connect to me.
I mean,
that's,
which is typically how,
that's how maybe Tony Robbins does it.
Right.
But,
uh,
for most of us it's more,
I mean,
we want to be your genuine self and be open to meeting new and interesting
people now and again,
essentially it's,
it's not a,
it's not a 24,
seven calling.
So I do believe that the various social channels make it possible to have to
discover and meet and have relationships with people,
with many more people that was ever possible without that,
uh,
for sure.
Um,
but it's not a numbers game either.
And so there's nothing that can be sort of a one to one exchange.
However,
the other connections work.
Um,
and I,
it in a way I learned that at Google too because it was the first kind of truly
international company I worked for where we'd have global offsite once a year
and everybody would be together for a week and we'd socialize.
And even if you only worked with somebody or other on your team a little bit,
just the fact that you'd had some social interaction and sometime together for a
week a year really strengthened the online relationship,
right,
that you'd go back to.
So I do think that's valuable,
but you can,
we're so used to sort of these sort of momentary touches with people,
whether it's a Twitter DM or even,
or even just an open tweet and a few of your friends respond and you have a
little thread,
uh,
you know,
linkedin was kind of built for a certain kind of online connection obviously.
And it works pretty well for that.
Um,
for,
for its,
its main purpose,
um,
Instagram,
uh,
like Twitter lets you follow people you don't know,
right?
And you can have a way to contact them.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
these are unlike Facebook,
which was not really designed for this sort of asymmetrical,
uh,
networking that,
that was much more,
you know,
your friends and family.
So,
uh,
so I do talk in the book about making use of those,
whichever ones you're comfortable on and where people are,
you're connecting to our are on a,
so that,
you know,
part of my day,
every day is probably a few Twitter dms,
a couple of text messages,
you know,
a couple of Facebook message messenger post or something like that.
Uh,
we're,
I'm just saying,
Hey,
thought of you saw this,
how are you,
you know,
let's talk soon.
It's not a,
it's not a heavy lift and it's not an obligatory response.
It's more just like,
I'm thinking of you right now.
So you mentioned asymmetrical connections and yeah.
So one thing I talked about a lot is asynchronous versus synchronous following.
And you know,
yeah.
In the early days it was very clear in Facebook,
I'm connected to Karen.
Karen's connected to me and it can't just be one way and Twitter,
and it was never the case,
you know,
so I could follow you and you didn't have to know who I was.
Right.
But I would see your updates and I could respond to you.
Yeah.
Uh,
and they've made it so that you can possibly only see responses from people who
you've already connected to or you can filter those down.
But do you see that there's some kind of value?
Is Does it even count as networking to just be aware of what people are doing?
Yes.
I mean it's a part of it.
Being aware and curious about what other people are doing is definitely a piece
of connecting to people because it just helps you when you,
it gives you context,
right?
For when you do have occasion to meet someone,
uh,
or you know,
want to meet someone that you have some,
you know,
a little more context.
And the context now is sort of richer than just the job history.
Right?
It,
it,
if,
if people have public accounts and you see that,
uh,
you know,
Google alum who's got an interesting approach and following as hunter walk,
who's now a VC with home brew.
And so he's posting,
you know,
he and his wife and daughter,
like go to a nail salon and they all get their nails painted and you know where
they,
I mean he's wherever he is.
And so you meet them and you think,
oh yeah,
you went to the Museum of ice cream or you know,
he uh,
he posted something funny that's fair game for a person you've never met because
he,
he posted it and it's public and you,
you have a little bit of ground to,
to,
you know,
be comment on together that you can sort of meet in the middle and be,
kind of sociable about a personable,
oh,
you mentioned that.
So in your book,
you talk a lot about,
you know,
doing the minimum standard to get into one of these networks,
but you have to be authentic.
You know,
you just tweet a few links
and then disappear.
But you also have people on the other side of the spectrum who share everything,
right?
And they don't stop and you meet them or whatever,
but they just continue and continue because there's different personalities that
take place in all these networks,
including,
I think you said it'd be at the communicator,
the first new pontificates makes comments and everything.
How do you find your lane or you just know what it is?
I mean,
no,
you the,
I mean you,
okay.
Here's,
I tried out now my favorite quote from the book from a guy named Ivan Meisner,
which is,
um,
think of networking less like hunting and more like farming or if you like
substitute gardening for farming.
So the idea is you're,
you're nurturing,
you're watering,
you're planting,
you're trimming your weeding,
you're plowing under,
you're replanting,
uh,
we're hunting and it's very transactional,
shall we say,
a one,
a one hit.
And so,
um,
you,
you're,
you know,
you don't,
I mean,
I kind of built my online connections over time just by,
oh,
this person's interesting.
I,
I have something in common with them.
They are interested in the same things I am,
uh,
I didn't meet them,
maybe it at Google,
but,
uh,
I followed them.
I know what they're doing now.
I want to be connected.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's a long game,
right?
And that's a,
it's a sort of ongoing process of cultivation and nurturing.
You talk a little bit about,
a lot about the loose connections.
Yeah.
And so when you look at these loose connections,
first of all,
you can define what that means and then the second for people who are loose
connection,
who might not have a direct overlap with a job,
does that matter?
Like,
do engineers need to connect to marketing people?
I would never mandate such a thing.
Uh,
no.
I mean it's,
it's based on sort of who you like.
I find an interesting thing though that,
uh,
in the time since I've left Google,
Google to me is such a worldclass network of people past and present.
I mean,
literally at the door here,
guy waved that I worked with 15 years ago.
I may be the last time,
some eight or 10 years ago,
and,
you know,
he couldn't stay the day I'm going to follow up and just say,
I miss you.
How are you?
You know,
uh,
it,
it's,
it's very,
um,
it can be very intermittent and there's no prescription about,
you know,
roles or history.
Even it,
it's more,
it's more just who do you like,
what associations you might have,
um,
with a place I'm sure a,
a company that fosters and encourages,
uh,
collaboration and cross team work and relationships and friendships,
does better in the longterm networking realm.
Then one that is very siloed.
Um,
just a guess.
You talk specifically about a all hands where people flew in from around the
globe and met here.
You still have relationships.
Yeah.
But the reality is,
you know,
both of you and I had dogs and we wouldn't,
we rather walk a dog around the park two times,
then go to some event in the city and walk around the room for two times.
I'd rather walk the dog.
Yeah.
So do I have to go to this corporate party?
Oh,
okay.
So,
uh,
global offsite is not probably,
an optional thing.
It's different than the holiday party,
I would say.
Uh,
you probably do have to participate fully in the offsite and that,
that's probably a good thing all around.
Uh,
I do write about corporate parties because they're not really networking
opportunities.
I don't think they are.
They are,
they may or may not be obligatory,
but they are a more of a political
statement perhaps.
And by that,
I mean I'm not at a company this big,
but it smaller companies,
you need to be seen as a team player,
right?
You need to be,
uh,
you know,
kind of part of the group and going along with things.
So in a small company,
uh,
it's not really,
it's not for fun.
It really is a work obligation to go to the holiday party.
What I say in the book is you do not have to stay all night at the company
party.
Make sure you're seen by a couple of the people you need to be seen by and then,
you know,
make a,
make an exit.
But they're not the same thing.
No,
absolutely not.
I was just bridging.
Okay.
So you also mentioned the book that the people that you need aren't always those
who are doing the hiring.
So can you explain that?
Yup.
In fact,
mostly you know,
you know how it works.
I mean mostly if your friend says,
uh,
I've already applied and I'd love to meet the hiring manager,
that's just not going to happen.
That's just not how it works.
Especially in a big company.
Um,
you don't meet the hiring manager before many other steps happen.
but you may want Intel about a team or the manager of the team or the future of
the product line or uh,
you know,
what,
what the dynamics are of the group and do they have cooperation from the other,
you know,
surrounding groups.
You may want all kinds of Intel about what it's like to work there and who the
other people are and all that kind of stuff.
So that's,
that's,
you know,
no one person is going to have,
like,
here's the entire answer to your job quest.
I know everything that you need to know about it.
It's going to be,
like I said,
a long game.
One person has this piece of the puzzle,
somebody knows about the product,
uh,
by ability or has strong opinions about it that are somewhat informed and you
know,
someone else has been on the team for a while.
Someone else can tell you maybe the history of how the group has evolved,
uh,
you know,
different people along the way that you might meet.
And so that's how you,
it's like a journalism effort really.
You're,
you're kind of the reporter trying to put together a story for yourself that
makes sense.
And that informs your interviews when you get to that point.
And so one thing that has happened are you,
when you started at Google,
it was literally a 17 years ago.
Yeah.
And so the company has changed,
but so have the products that are being offered for sure as the technology.
Yeah.
And so I think about this sometimes,
you know,
my previous role and the previous company I once asked to have everybody's
birthdays so that we could publish them in an internal newsletter.
The enterprising HR person who responded,
no,
only sent me everyone's birthdays,
but included their birth year.
Ah,
and then sorted from oldest to youngest and I was down at the bottom.
I was like the third youngest person in the company.
Clearly personally identifiable information,
big mistake.
But I'm no longer the third youngest person in the company.
Right.
Neither of you.
And as things have changed,
and you talked about the fact that sixty's the new 40,
but also it's really hard to reboot your career at age 40 or 50 or 60.
Sure.
So is networking more important because the world is changing underneath it or
do you just going to hold onto your people and move forward?
Honestly,
I have to say it's more important,
um,
holding on and sort of,
you know,
hoping no one's really noticing is,
I mean that's a,
has a limited success rate right.
At were,
um,
if you continue,
if basically if you have a growth mindset,
if you're,
if you're curious,
if you're willing to evolve,
if you,
if you're open to learning new things,
open to meeting new people,
open to having new thoughts,
that's the thing that keeps you going.
Correct.
Um,
and you know,
in a way I used to joke that I was the oldest person at Google at the time
because I am older than Eric.
However,
uh,
then Google hired Vint cerf and Vint is older than I am.
And so he became kind of an inspiration for me because he's awesome and like an
insane world traveler in this three piece suits.
So,
um,
it's really not,
uh,
we all have a age discrimination.
I do too.
I will characterize someone as being too old and I mean it's in their mind,
you know,
it's like they don't have,
they don't have a growth mindset I guess is maybe the way to say it.
But,
um,
we all have to kind of watch for that.
But I think the,
the answer,
if you fear it is better,
step out a little wider rather than kind of hope no one notices me
sticking with demographics that are uncomfortable for $800.
Yeah,
you are a female.
And so as a woman who's networking,
those are,
I mean,
you talked about Twitter being a really hostile place for weather sometimes and
you kind of railed against it and not talking about while you worked there.
But I mean,
as a platform,
just to clarify.
Yeah.
But as a female who's outwardly networking to find that it's easier than what
you're thinking,
your male counterparts,
you're having it or is it harder?
Do you find that going out for coffee or sending an email,
um,
to a,
sometimes gets the wrong response?
Are People looking at it the wrong way?
So to me,
for me where I am and you know,
my,
I'm 67,
so for me the,
the age factor has kind of trumped the woman factor.
Uh,
and in a way that's lucky.
I think it's very interesting because I was considered,
you know,
maybe an anomalous person who worked in silicon valley,
but nonetheless,
someone who kind of fit in and,
uh,
you know,
had been around a long time.
I mean,
I had some credibility,
uh,
so that,
um,
uh,
helped me,
I was not party to a bunch of uncomfortable exchanges.
On the other hand,
when you're older,
you're also more invisible.
And in a way I find that kind of a superpower because nobody pays attention to
you and it's,
and if you're a woman,
you know that you're there also not listening to what you're saying in a
meeting,
but which is not always good.
But,
uh,
at the same time,
it's kind of interesting.
Maybe it all ties to being an introvert because I observe and I watch and I kind
of take my own council and kind of react later.
But I can observe the scene and watch how people are.
But I do think that for me personally,
I'm,
I'm sure I wasn't seriously considered certain times in my career,
not,
not just at Google by any means for different roles or something because some
guy was friends with another guy.
I'm sure that has happened,
but at the same time,
you know,
I mean,
I made my own way.
Uh,
and I think honestly,
being kind of a of a few years ahead was beneficial to me oddly,
and never really gotten my way at all at Google or Twitter for that matter.
And earlier on,
uh,
I was at a lot of smaller companies and you know,
computer publications,
um,
where there wasn't as much of an age consciousness gap at that time.
Uh,
and it didn't have this yet.
So maybe that made a difference too.
So when you talked you and you introduced your book in mountain view,
this was about a couple of my second book sink had a book signing.
So I asked you a question,
which I'm going to repeat.
So you're already ready for this one.
Okay.
So at Twitter you tweet and you got 140 characters.
Now it's 280 maybe you were able to add a photo,
but it's pretty concise and you're owned by a container and a blog is more open
ended,
but it's not a hundred pages.
Right.
Your book is.
So how did you take on this uncomfortable challenge of having to write for a
long form?
And obviously what you're doing is kind of like a book tour and a book signing
tour.
These are probably outside your comfort zone because you haven't done it before.
Right.
How'd you do it?
Uh,
well,
you know,
I,
I mean,
I knew enough about publishing to say,
if I get an agent and they sell a proposal,
I meant I'm gonna follow this adventure.
I know,
I know what's generally entailed here.
I'm,
I'll,
I'll do it.
I just thought that I did know it would be a problem to write long because I'm
not used to writing long.
I mean,
I've written for online,
you know,
a thousand words is more than enough most of the time.
So He'd get the contract and it says 60 to 80,000 words and I thought,
I'm just not going to pay attention to that right now.
I can't.
But the,
but the simple answer to writing long is you just have to break it down.
So I would pay attention not to the metal length.
And,
you know,
I would be more like follow,
I had to learn how to make a good outline,
which I hadn't done since school.
And then literally go to the outline and say,
okay,
that's next.
And then that's next.
I mean it was,
that was hard.
That was really,
you know,
Butt in seat type work to,
to make,
and then one day,
uh,
my editor said,
let's just count up how,
how far you are,
you know,
and she just,
I did it all on Google docs.
And so she just sort of did a rough count of every chapter.
I was like,
wow,
I'm at 43,000 words already,
so you will see it.
It's not a long book.
There's sidebars with exercises.
There's epigraphs for every chapter.
Uh,
cause I,
that's as long as it needed to be in the,
actually,
that's what my editor told me to.
He didn't have to kind of overly repeat,
but it was,
it was a slog.
It was something I had to learn.
Same with going out and talking about it.
I mean,
in a way I'm not,
uh,
it's not my natural state,
but I,
if I had to do it for the rest of my life,
I don't know.
But for some period of months or a year,
I enjoy it because it's not constant and it's fun to talk about and especially
to get the questions.
So you talk a lot about getting the first role at Google through people,
you know,
and using the network and helping other people forward and similar at Twitter,
someone you knew and your existing relationship got you there.
So that sets up this kind of wall where people who don't know you can't get in.
And when you talk about Google getting a million resumes,
a quarter a day,
whatever,
it looks like,
it's a lot.
So there's a two piece on this.
First,
does that mean online job submissions are dead and recruiters should just do
something else?
And then the third thing,
which I'm concerned about is if you only getting in by who,
you know,
doesn't that just submit the diversity problem that we already have?
That's very good question.
But I would say,
um,
they're recruiters are not,
are not going away because there are still lots of jobs,
uh,
in the world that,
follow this,
you know,
CV submission,
uh,
picked out of the pile,
you know,
phone screening process that that goes on.
Um,
the question is really about the higher level jobs and the executive roles and
the roles that are kind of built on relationships and have fostered
relationships with other people in other places.
That's an interesting thing to explore it for me personally,
uh,
I'm,
that's why I'm open to meeting everybody all the time and giving advice.
Even if I don't have direct advice,
I'll go,
I mean,
I will literally Google like a good how to article and send it to someone and
say,
I can't help more than this,
but this is a good source for what you need to do next or what you need to know.
It is a very good question about the idea of,
uh,
you know,
this sort of friends of friends and I don't have a single good answer to that.
I would say that the more people in hiring positions and,
uh,
incumbents accompanies companies are aware of that the more they broadly debt
work,
right for roles,
not just the old,
you know,
example would be ivy league is where the only place we go versus all kind of all
of other kinds of schools.
Now I think we have to say that they don't all have to be four year colleges.
We want to look at a bunch of different variables.
Um,
it,
it's gonna just be a piecemeal improvement.
I think,
uh,
where someone says,
we are determined to find,
we're going to look in more sources and we're going to have a broader definition
of the role and we do not want,
you know,
uh,
the friendly person that we already know we'd like to have a beer with and the,
you know,
famous,
um,
notion.
In fact,
I did interview,
um,
an HR,
uh,
executive because this question of cultural fit has come up a lot,
right?
This kind of shorthand for it,
you know,
they,
they fit with us.
They're like us,
you know,
that kind of thing.
And,
uh,
she said that at least in her circle in of HR and training and development
people,
um,
they,
they knew that was a bad construct and they,
they don't use that.
They don't want to reference that.
They think instead about one's cultural contribution to a company,
uh,
which is,
could be narrowly defined,
but hopefully as much more broadly defined as they have their passions and their
interests and they're not all the same.
And they,
they don't all match each other.
They're more like they bring a richness.
So they have a,
they have a contribution to make culturally and socially as well as,
uh,
the job skills.
And I liked that way of thinking about it,
but it,
it takes,
you know,
discipline to actually apply that in every,
all the,
all the steps in the,
in a hiring process.
And so you often talk about having this large network of connections,
but do you also have a really tight network of close connections where you can
be unfiltered in
a sat?
Just a relief to not have to be this public face?
Uh,
well for sure,
but I'm not sure I'm this public face that much of the time to be honest.
I mean,
we all do,
you know,
when you actually get together with someone face to face,
uh,
that's hopefully going to be more personable,
personal and more,
um,
you know,
unfiltered than even watching what you tweet or something like that or what you
or what you choose to write about.
Um,
we all need that too.
You know,
we need the intimacy of the actual,
you know,
direct connection as well as I think this broader world that,
that helps us in a lot of things that we do.
So,
cliff,
I think we have the option for anyone else in the audience who's live to ask
questions if you do have them.
Uh,
so you mentioned the levy who is great,
uh,
what other reporters were good to work with and it was bad to work with.
Well,
I,
I mean actually it's interesting,
the whole scene has changed so much.
Um,
you know,
uh,
it used to be there were the big band stream outlets and then a bunch of
bloggers and now we can't really make that differentiation as is the same way.
So Steven Levy is a wonderful long form reporter and not a sort of day of scoop
type reporter.
Um,
you know,
there's actually too many to name,
um,
who were covering Google.
But you know,
most of the,
maybe this is a fudging on the question,
I don't know.
Uh,
but you know,
it's a relationship business too,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's ongoing conversations and by the way,
not just when you need something.
I mean,
it's,
it really mirrors the same idea of connecting with people so that you can give
context and be off the record and kind of let them know something's coming
without saying what it is.
And if it's a,
it's very much a good relationship network.
Um,
I would say that the publications,
uh,
you know,
have changed so much,
buzzfeed,
uh,
and,
um,
uh,
vox is,
you know,
maybe these are things that didn't exist a few years ago by sometimes there are
many more outlets than the main stream.
The reporters change though because there are not in a long term stable jobs for
the most part.
And so they move around.
So someone like Mike Isaac for example,
uh,
you know,
kind of cut his teeth a little bit at recode,
I'm wired and now he's at the New York Times,
um,
uh,
finishing his book on Uber,
which we're all waiting for us.
So,
um,
you know,
uh,
the cast of characters in a way has changed and some of the practice has changed
because it's not about,
I mean years before even Google for a long time in PR,
it was the long form,
which was magazines over three months out the short form,
which was newspapers.
And then here came this other thing,
the blogs,
right.
And it's like,
it's just some,
so much a different landscape.
Now.
I was wondering like what your perspective is on like networking events where
it's,
cause you talk a lot about the current relationships where you're working with
someone,
but where it's a,
you know,
there's a networking event that you're hosting that someone's hosting,
whether like would you attend it or not or what your take is.
If it was really just like the purpose of this event is to like make people and
come home with business cards or contacts beamed between bones.
I questioned like,
that's like a weird speed dating kind of thing.
And that's why I think people hate the idea of networking is that's what they
think of is hotel ballroom.
I have,
I'm gonna make myself stay 30 minutes and I'm going to come away with three
business cards or you know,
whatever.
That's what,
but if it was a conference,
uh,
then that's a little different where there may be common interest.
You might be there for a day or two.
You're going to have a little small talk with this one and that one.
There might be a legitimate moment of connection.
You wouldn't do a whole networking thing there.
You'd follow up,
but that's more natural than just like network to find your next job at this
event.
That is about that.
I think I wouldn't do that personally and I think those are,
that's their painful,
those things.
I don't know if anyone's had a good experience at one of those.
Does anyone do those?
Uh,
if I could ask you to summarize the whole book in one formula.
Well,
it wouldn't be a formula because I'm a liberal arts major.
you know,
it,
it might be this guy's quote Ivan Meisner.
Uh,
you know,
networking is more like farming than hunting to paraphrase.
Um,
in other words,
it's seasonal.
It's a long game and you're continuing to attended.
So in essence,
I think that would be what I'd say.
The other thing I might add is,
um,
people want to help each other.
It's just you have to help,
you have to give context and have some kind of richness around what you're
seeking are asking.
But people like to help each other if they can.
Uh,
when you reach out to people and was an introvert,
I have a problem where you don't know what to say.
Like you don't have a purpose in mind.
Like what do you do that and if you reach out to people,
do they always respond to you?
Especially with people where you have nothing really you need to say and you
don't have,
you don't know each other that well.
I think I'd wonder why you're reaching out in the first place.
Is it,
is it,
what would make you reach out to someone you don't know?
Uh,
like in general because
like someone tells you it's a good idea to yeah,
make more contact.
Okay.
You need context,
right?
So if,
if it's,
if it's just like linkedin kind of set this up in a way that is,
I guess somewhat useful,
but,
but not entirely useful.
Right.
Where you send somebody that canned language,
I'd like to join your network.
Don't do that.
Right?
Don't,
don't just send the canned message that's not from you.
Uh,
they make it easy to overwrite that and say,
I'm interested in,
you know,
your career as a product manager.
I'm interested in how you got to that company or what,
you know,
you've written about something in Ai.
Um,
I want to know more about that.
So you,
you immediately brings some reason for it,
uh,
to the front.
And that's when people are like,
oh,
that's kind of flattering and maybe I,
you know,
I,
I will respond to that.
However briefly,
no,
people do not always respond.
Um,
and that's just kind of,
uh,
the way it goes.
I think the law of large numbers or something,
if you're trying,
I do find that the better,
your odds are always better if you can say,
I have a friend of so and so's or even better,
your friend introduces you.
But beyond that,
uh,
if,
if you're just reached,
you say,
I know somebody at someone has spoken highly of you or I heard you talk or I
read your paper,
um,
I would love to have,
uh,
you know,
20 minutes or could you respond to this and send me a link to your paper?
Or could we have a 20 minute call?
Or um,
if we're both local,
you know,
could I buy you coffee one day or you know,
something like that.
That it's like not a heavy obligation for them.
There's not a time limit.
And you're saying I'd really like to know more and maybe you don't ask it all at
once.
Maybe it's just me.
I ask you a few questions about this thing and you know,
I think people will respond if they have that kind of context.
Maybe it's not as full as you'd like or sometimes people will say,
yeah actually I'm,
I'm at based on who you are and your background.
Yeah,
I would love to talk shop with you about it.
Cause I can see you have some background that's related,
something like that.
So,
but you do bring something,
you're not asking a favor in the sense of,
please help me.
You're just saying,
I'd like to know more or this interests me.
Can you,
you know,
would you take time to tell me more?
It's not like I need a job and I have to apply tomorrow.
You know,
that's when that will not get a response,
a good response most of the time.
Hi,
thanks for coming.
So,
um,
when I read about the history of companies like Google and Twitter and all these
other technology companies,
how they were started,
how they were felons,
and it's usually a story about a small hand full of people who somehow know each
other and then make this great company.
And when,
uh,
and,
and when you read about,
oh,
how do you start a startup?
It's it,
it always skips.
That step is always like,
you have your team and now I make your startup here,
here,
here's the steps.
How do you get how you get a capital for venture capital funding and all these
other things?
How do you go from having this network that you've cultivated to act,
to having like a team to yeah.
That,
uh,
that,
um,
you can use to actually take steps to start things like this?
Very good question.
I mean,
I'm only speaking as an observer here,
have the same history you're talking about,
but it seems like,
uh,
the probably the first thought isn't accompany,
but like is it a product?
Is it a thing we can make?
That's interesting.
Uh,
if it's,
if it's engineers and technical people,
um,
and money doesn't come into it for a while,
uh,
but it's more like,
is this a good idea?
Is this something,
um,
you know,
either interesting or groundbreaking or does something different with technology
in some way?
Um,
I mean most Google's pretty unusual in that most companies don't have sort of an
early team of employees that is as cohesive for as long as has been the case at
Google.
That's really rare I think.
And so typically it's more like,
uh,
you know,
the Beatles where it's like,
it was stu best,
but he died or I mean,
stew Sutcliff,
he died.
And then it was Pete best,
but he didn't kind of work out and we didn't like him.
And so then it was Ringo.
You know,
it was like when I read about companies starting,
it's often okay,
this was the beginning.
And then in fact I just met a guy who said I was part of a startup.
It was successful,
but I realized I didn't want to do it.
So I bailed.
I sold my half to the other ones that I'm out.
People shift around.
But essentially it does come from either we have a good idea cause we've been
fooling around together and come up with something.
Or in a lot of cases now it's like we worked somewhere on something before,
but we always had this thing we talked about as a thing we'd like to try.
But there are so many steps between that and you know,
even these VC or anything but did becoming a company and we had lots,
um,
you know,
don't obviously get that far.
But it is interesting.
What you're saying though about it is kind of your personal network of people
you know.
Well at first,
right.
Not,
it's not,
you're not,
you know,
discovering people on Instagram for your company or it's people you know,
and,
and trust in the beginning and,
you know,
uh,
think deeply about stuff.
Um,
and then,
you know,
it's a long,
long journey after that,
I think.
And so how that happens,
I mean,
we're lucky to live in a place and,
and in a time when there's so many things that are like incubators and,
you know,
Angel Investors and small accelerators and things that are from very early stage
just fooling around,
you know,
startups that are,
uh,
not formulated at all,
but it's a few people trying to figure something out.
And by the way,
they're networking and talking to other people and testing out their ideas.
So it's very hit and miss.
But,
um,
I think that's what,
I dunno,
makes it seem so using a small conversation that turns into an idea.
Yeah.
It's a good way of saying it.
It's great to be here.